ouais je crois que je sorte en boîte
pour mon âge et que c'est plus possible
j'en parle dans le spectacle je dis que
ma grand-mère me demande pourquoi je
suis toujours pas marié ouais que j'ai
un rapport privilégié avec ma grand-mère
et elle me dit mais pourquoi tu es
toujours pas mariée et je lui dis cool
j'ai l'impression que j'ai un peu le
syndrome de Peter Pan j'ai encore envie
de faire la fête j'ai envie d'être
dehors tous les soirs j'ai envie de
vivre quoi
et elle me dit cette phrase que je
trouve très mignonne elle dit en fait
toi tu es exactement comme mes dents et
je lui dis c'est-à-dire mamie elle me
dit bah tu passes toutes tes nuits
dehors
[Musique]
j'ai pas allumé la télévision j'ai pas
écouté les infos depuis je sais pas 4 5
jours peut-être et c'est dingue parce
que tout à coup on a l'impression qu'il
se passe rien
c'est mauvaise nouvelle qu'on entend
tous les jours j'ai redécouvrir en
rallumant la télévision bien sûr et la
radio mais là je me suis bouché les
oreilles
joyeux anniversaire Flo laissez-nous
vous présenter notre cadeau
d'anniversaire pour Bigflo le Bigflo Oli
un Monopoly 100% personnalisé on vous
montre le but c'est de devenir le flow
le plus riche nous avons la monnaie qui
est la flo avant de jouer choisis ton
pion est-ce que tu as un Bigflo est-ce
que tu le T'choupi au lit en plus égal
plus pour Léna une petite part de pizza
ou le S2
[Musique]